in case you haven't heard by now there
were many eye-catching scenes in
Avengers end game from deaths we didn't
see coming to twist that continued on
until the very last spring
one such attention-grabbing moment
involved Captain America and his iconic
shield the sequence in question happens
during the climax of the film during
which all the costumed heroes who were
dusted away re materialized to join the
fight against the mad Titan from the
past
immediately fans can recognize that this
Thanos looks a little different compared
to how they're used to seeing him on the
silver screen not only is he rocking his
gold armor but he also carries a massive
dual bladed weapon past Thanos utilizes
it to its full capabilities
demonstrating that it's even deadlier
than the weapons of his opponents when
Thanos gets up close and personal with
Captain America the mad Titan slashes
away a caps vibranium shield breaking
off large chunks of it until it's about
half its original size classic Thanos
but how could that hose break a shield
previously thought to be completely
indestructible Avengers end game
director Joe Russo offered up an answer
and it's an intriguing one speaking with
comicbook.com Russo hinted that
vibranium might not be as durable as
people have believed it to be
despite black panther once explaining
that the kinetic energy absorbing metal
is the most powerful one in the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe a media that
made of vibranium the strongest
substance in the universe struck the
continent of Africa
the director said that Thanos's weapon
is probably made of something more
powerful the best weapon for the
greatest villain Russo said clearly
Bannos is a thousand-year-old character
who has fought everyone in the universe
and is the greatest he's the Genghis
Khan of the universe so he would have
the greatest weapon so there you have it
Thanos is the greatest and his sword is
just better like destiny you can't run
from the power of an awesome sword Joe
Russo then noted that Thanos may have
crafted his double bladed sword weapon
with the help of a tree the famed
weapons forger who created Thor's mill
near and helped the god of thunder
forges battle axe Stormbreaker an
infinity war as Russo put it
Thanos may have gotten in contact with
Eitri traveled to Nineveh Lear and
gained access to a material even
stronger than vibranium to forge his
double-edged weapon with even more
interesting than that is the idea that
perhaps Thanos had each recreate the
shield breaking weapon around the same
time he forged this Infinity Gauntlet
Brousseau explains he knows of treet
he's been to e tree to have his glove
created did he have them create his
blade as well potentially but it's
interesting that it could destroy the
shield regardless of how and when Thanos
had his double-ended sword weapon forged
what's arguably more noteworthy is what
the weapon could be made of given that
it's tough enough to crack vibranium
thanassis weapon must be comprised of
another incredibly strong metal perhaps
adamantium the other super sturdy metal
known in the Marvel Universe adamantium
is as fans will recall the metal alloy
bonded to x-men hero Wolverine's
skeleton
taking into consideration the existence
of adamantium in the Marvel Universe
plus Russo's Coit comments about it
being interesting that Thanos's weapon
could destroy Captain America's shield
it's possible that it could be revealed
in the future that the weapon was indeed
made with adamantium the substance
hasn't explicitly appeared in an MCU
film even though it got a nod and a
special feature on the blu-ray version
of Iron Man 2 and a loose reference in
Netflix's daredevil but it has been a
staple throughout 20th Century Fox's
x-men movies since Disney has absorbed
Fox and bought the film rights to many
Marvel Comics characters it previously
couldn't use in the MCU now might be the
perfect time to introduce adamantium
into the franchise who knows everything
means something in the MCU so it's
probably only a matter of time before
fans discover what Thanos is shield
shattering weapon was really made of
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Avengers and game are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]